hey what's up my name's Samuel leaves
I'm a very successful property investor
and I'm on a mission to help as many
people to achieve financial freedom
through property as possible
this year alone currently we've helped
71 people become financially free in
property which is just incredible and
one of the questions I get asked all the
time is how do you stay motivated for
success because I think that the scale
in poverty is really important but also
the motivation to actually take action
on the skill is also just as important
and many people are looking for the
detail in what to go and do but the
thing is unless you're motivated you're
never going to actually do it anyway so
in this video I want to just answer the
question what keeps me so motivated what
gets me up in up every morning excited
how do I have so much energy and
hopefully that will you know help you
guys in your journey so I think firstly
is willpower everyone says I need more
well power you know I don't believe in
well power I believe in why power what I
mean by why power is a reason for why
you want to succeed so rather than just
thinking I want to do a I want to get a
property deal you know I really want to
get a property deal but they didn't so I
cannot be bothered to pick up the phone
to the age it can't be bothered to go
and be the deal kind of be bothered to
go to the networking event run rather
than the why being I want a property
deal the why should be something that's
actually far greater than that so when
I'm mentoring people often ask them I'll
ask them why like seven times why do you
want me to mentor you because I want to
learn about property why because I want
to be financially free why because I
want to quit my job
why because I'm tired of being someone
I'm tired of waking up at 6:30 in the
morning I just want to wake up when I
finish sleeping okay so now it goes a
little bit deeper and then when you can
get that why and remind yourself of why
you're wee
wanting to do this that helped so I
think for me I have a dream board which
is all the things that I want to achieve
all the people that I want to help the
real true reasons you're spending on my
family going out to villages in Africa
where people have nothing in helping
educate and support and provide provide
practically for those but this is stuff
that's make me want to do it
leaving a legacy the kick that I get
from helping other people achieving
property when I've got the why real
strong then what happens is it helps me
and I don't suddenly need the world
power so I think that's that's the first
thing second thing is how do you stay
motivated it's all about environment
like if you are around people who are
unmotivated boring people doom and gloom
negative then that's exactly what you're
going to be like because you're in that
environment and I don't even have a
haddock way you've been in a really good
mood everything's going great and you're
laughing and you joke in and
everything's fun and then you walk into
a different room and the atmosphere is
totally different it just and it just is
surely just like a balloon being popped
that you know just and suddenly your
whole energy change is the atmosphere is
different because the environment is
different and you cannot be that person
you cannot be that happy silly person in
that room because it's just not right
it's not the invite environment and in
the same way I think if you want to be
motivated if you want to be positive if
you want to be driven if you want to be
an action taker what you've got to do is
you're going to put yourself in the
environment where other people are doing
what you want to do so find the rooms
where people are who you want to be like
and hang around those people and I heard
someone want to say that if you put a
baby shark like an 8 inch shark into a
fishbowl two things will happen it will
either die or it will just stay eight
inches forever so you get imagine that
an adult shark eight inches long it's
just insane but in the same way if you
don't put yourself into a bigger
environment where people think bigger
and take bigger risks and take bigger
action if you stay in a small
minded environment then that's what
you're going to be like forever so I
think the second thing is just get
yourself into a different environment
get around people that are successful
get around people they're cheering you
on and I think if you're in a good
environment it just it just makes you it
makes it much easier to take action and
do things when we've run the property
investors crash course which is a two
day program where we teach people how to
do property people are literally at that
program making more deals and making
more phone calls and booking more
viewings than they have done in the
previous six months and the reason is is
because the atmosphere is so easy to
make calls to agents the atmosphere is
so easy to put offers forward because
everyone's doing it but at home in the
different atmosphere it can be totally
different so make your home the kind of
environment in the kind of atmosphere
where it's easy to win double second
thing third thing is to act in spite of
your mood so believe it or not oh I
don't always feel like being really
energetic taking massive action even
doing videos I don't always feel like it
but what you'll find is when you just
take action and step out in spite of how
you feel you very quickly get in the
mood so let's say this video let's say I
don't feel like doing this video but if
I say you know it doesn't matter how I
feel I've made a commitment I'm just
going to put the camera on sit in the
chair and start talking and then what
happened is very quickly I'll just very
quickly get in the mood because I'm
doing it anyway I don't feel like doing
your run but what you'll find is when
you put your trainers on and just step
outside the house and start very quickly
it just happens and suddenly you just
find yourself getting in the mood and I
think in the same way is to fill your
diary up with stuff that you know you
need to do even if you don't feel like
it and and be disciplined because when
you start doing it happens it'll become
a bit shovel it become part of your
routine and part of my routine is taking
massive action is taken it's taking risk
it's putting offers on properties he's
speaking on stage it's doing pop my
routine he's doing videos putting them
out there so how to stay motivated
don't rely on feeling motivated rely on
being dedicated to take action because
of your why because of your reason
get in the right environment for around
the right people so that it makes it a
whole lot easier as well and those are
my secrets to how I stay motivated and
how I continue taking massive action and
even even even though I don't need to
even though I've got a really good
property portfolio I don't need to do
these videos I don't need to run a
training business I don't need to keep
buying more houses I'm doing it because
I'm driven I'm driven to succeed
way more than I currently am because I'm
in the environment I'm hanging around
people that are more successful than I
am and I've got a big reason where I
want to do something bigger and I want
to leave the world better than I found
it and I want to grow something that's
greater than me and outlives me and I'm
gonna do that even if I don't feel like
it and that's my secrets also I think
it's really helpful to inspire you to
see other people and to see what other
people are doing and how they're killing
it I find that really motivates me as
well so if you want to watch a 21 year
old absolutely killing it in property
I'd really suggest you check out the
interview that I did with James
Armstrong which is right here also if
you want to spend two days at the
property investors crash course tickets
on the house get yourself booked on
right here but whatever you do don't
forget to subscribe to the channel so
you can watch more videos you never miss
one you do that right here so a
notification Belon I'll see you next
time
[Music]